I have recently, two weeks ago, purchased an infrared soda,
brand name, TheraSanche. By durable,
boarded routine is now to drink 16 to 20 ounces of water,
take many clay or activated charcoal
at zealine to bind toxins. So those are binders that
tend to stay in the gut zealine, could be absorbed, it could be a
key later as well. Before I begin my 30 minutes of rebounding,
prior to popping it in the soda, and then
remineralize with greens and some sea salt following my soda.
I'm currently using the soda for 30 minutes and 160 degrees. I stay inside the
soda for another 20 minutes to allow my body to continue to
sweat. It is slowly returned to normal body
temperature before I do skin brushing and then take a shower.
Any info or guidelines that I should know as I continue?
Well, personally, well, many people cannot tolerate 30
minutes of soda at 160 degrees. So you're able to tolerate that and
really sweat. So what's the benefit of doing a soda is
you're sweating, you're helping to take pressure off of your liver
because you're using your skin as a portal of detoxification so that
could be really beneficial. Is there a temperature time
goal to work up to that would be best for breast cancer treatment?
I really think you're at that maximum. Typically, I don't recommend people do more
than 30 minutes a day. I've studied and I typically
recommend people to start at 140 degrees. So you're at 160 doing 30 minutes already.
I certainly wouldn't do any more than that. So I think you're doing great.
Kudos to you, fantastic. Personally, when I was doing a lot of
soda, I couldn't do more than 20 minutes. I just would go
stir crazy. Even in my zip up soda, I didn't have a
neurosurgeon, but I have the other brand. It's still, I just couldn't do it.
A lot of people are that way. They first start to use a soda like that.
They can only do it for five minutes and this can't handle it anymore.
You got to go slow and work up. So you're doing great, you're kind of at the max right now.